After working in
R, you often want
to save your work so that you
can easily re-run commands
and rebuild models.
There are several
ways of doing this,
but the method we
recommend is by using
what's called a script file.
Let's open a new script file.
Go to File, New Document, on
a Mac, and File, New Script,
on a PC.
This will pop up a
blank script file.
You can copy and
paste any commands
that you've run in your
console into the script file.
For example, say we want to
save the table commands we ran.
Let's Copy the
first table command
and then Paste it
into the script file.
We can also take the
first tapply command
we ran, Copy and Paste
it into our script file.
Now, if you highlight
these lines of code
in the script file and press
Command-Enter on a Mac,
and Control-r on a PC, it
will run these lines of code
in your R console.
So if you save this
file and then reopen it
when you start R next time, you
can easily rerun any commands
that you ran in this R session.
A lot of times it's
easier to just write
commands in your script file
and run them in your console
because then they'll always
be saved in your script file.
You can add comments
in your script file
by using the pound sign.
If you type pound,
and then some comment
describing your script file, and
then highlight the whole thing
and press Control-r
or Command-Enter,
you'll see that the comment
runs in the console,
but nothing happens.
R recognizes this as a comment.
If you want to save the
output of your R session
in your console, I recommend
just saving it as a text file.
In your console, you can
go to file, Save to file,
and this will save your
output as a text file.
You won't be able
to easily rerun
this in R like the
script file, but it
will have the summary
output of what you did.
When you close R,
it will ask you
if you want to save
your workspace.
Make sure you have everything
you want in a script file
and then don't worry about
saving your workspace.
These are the basics
of R. We'll see
a lot more in the
rest of this class.
But hopefully you've
seen in this lecture
how powerful R can be.
In just one lecture, we
performed insightful data
analysis on an
interesting data set.